were there other things when making the
film whether it was choosing an editor
or choosing a location I know Julia
Cameron always talks about how intuition
often whispers to us it's not like this
loud booming so were there other
instances where things fell into line
because you listened to hear so now
there was one of the most fun examples
in the whole three-year process was we
were about a year and a half into it and
I wanted to bring dr. Joe Dispenza from
what the bleep end of the film because
even though he talks a lot about the
brain I knew that he was also you know
about the connection of the heart in the
brain and so we'd been asking and asking
can we film him can we film him and I'm
sitting in my hometown of Iowa where hi
working to Moines Iowa with my clients
and I get a call from dr. Joe's
assistant said you can film him two days
from now in Chicago okay he said yes I'm
sitting here in Iowa going I don't have
any camera crew in Chicago so I called
my editor in my director in Sedona and
said could you give me a couple names of
who I can who we could maybe shoot he
gave me two names and I had this feeling
call this guy I liked his name Ned
Miller I called Ned he picked up on the
second ring I said Ned it's Who I am
what I'm doing could you by any chance
two days from now do some shooting and
this project about the heart he didn't
know anything more about it didn't tell
him who he said oh I would love to do it
it sounds intriguing but I already have
a ticket to something that's
non-refundable and I'm just really am
looking forward and I have to go and so
here's that gut intuition again saying
Ned would that happen to be dr. Joe
Dispenza and his in his presentation he
said it is and he said I'm there I'll
just put my camera in the car my tickets
already paid and that's how the filming
of dr. Joe Dispenza happen in this film
you can't as I say to my client Simon's
you can't make this up you just have to
follow that intuition and trust it and
trust it and trust it because if I'd
said it's impossible I can't do this in
two days and I'm in Iowa and I don't
know anybody but we trusted and here we
have you know a wonderful contribution
of a leading luminary in the film we
you have other wonderful people as well
can you give us some of their names we
have Mary Morrissey the narrator the
film who is a very powerful leader in
consciousness and she contributes her
experience with awarding Nelson Mandela
the Peace Prize with a delegation of
five so she was the the powerhouse
female narrator that I was trusting was
going to happen to come to the film we
have gregg braden that many people know
his work and fractal time and deep truth
we have common tipping a personal hero
of my own my own two very important
turning point in my life was meeting him
who created radical forgiveness and we
have the indigenous elders from a
variety of places around the world who
contributed their wisdom and to our film
to really emphasize the message of the
heart
you